judge issues gag order and rebukes Trump
after social media post attacking his
Clerk and uh we also have this one from
Dr Kelly Ward judges threatening real
Donald Trump with jail if he doesn't
remove this post from truth social well
of course we will highlight that post so
you can all know the news Trump truthed
Schumer's girlfriend Allison R
Greenfield is running his case against
me this case against me how disgraceful
disgraceful this case should be
dismissed immediately linking to a uh
tweet from judicial protest saying why
is Judge enron's principal law clerk
Allison R Greenfield ping around with
Chuck Schumer well I guess because of
this the judge says Trump is here by
gaged which I find funny considering the
Jud judges allowing cameras in the
courtroom this whole thing is very
obviously an attempt to drain Trump's
energy and resources to attack his
Circle and cause political damage to
interfere in the 2024 election
absolutely I mean that's what they've
all been about this is another example
this this one is particularly egregious
if you look at the fact that you have
Leticia James the Attorney General of
the state of New York who ran a campaign
not on doing what was best for the
people of the state of New York not
locking up criminals not really going
after the hard crime my gosh New York
City is a mess you just take that City
in and of itself let alone the rest of
the state she's supposed to be looking
out for she ran a campaign where she
said I'm gonna be a real pain in his ass
I'm gonna go in to the Attorney
General's office every day suing him and
then going home she never cared a second
about anything other than Donald Trump
so here you have a situation where there
is no plaintiff there is no person that
was injured there is no issue whatsoever
on behalf of these Banks who made tens
if not hundreds of millions of dollars
off of these loans that they gave the
Trump organization and yet here we are
with my father-in-law now for the second
day and I assume tomorrow as well in
court in downtown Manhattan over this
absolute nonsense and these people want
to dissolve his business make no mistake
about it they want to inflict maximum
pain yes they want to inflict maximum
pain they ordered it this judge ordered
it in a summary judgment before even
hearing all the facts of everything when
he told everyone Mara Lago is worth $18
million what an utter joke and then
whenever people said well what does that
mean what what do you want dissolved he
said I'm not ready to rule on that yet
it is wild stuff it is Banana Republic
at at best I got to I got to read this
uh this quote here this is too good the
judge said this morning one of the
defendants one of the defendants posted
on a social media account a disparaging
untrue and personally identifying post
about a member of my staff although I
have since ordered the post deleted and
apparently it was it was also emailed
out to millions of other recipients the
judge said in court personal attacks of
any member of my court staff are
unacceptable inappropriate and I will
not tolerate them I just love that the
that Trump emailed it out to everybody
just to make sure you got it hey look
you can order someone to delete a post
on social media but once the email is
sent it's sent yeah that's that's that's
the benefit of doing of of using email I
just think it's absolutely absurd that
the judge is telling Donald Trump he
can't
speak this is unrelated to the trial
when when it comes to civil suits it is
unsurprising that there will be uh gag
orders right if you if if if person a su
person B it's it it is normal for the
judge to be like guys don't disparage
each other Donald Trump is talking about
the court MH I mean so you know maybe
someone might advise him not to do it I
just think the Judge putting cameras in
the courtroom issuing a issuing a
summary judgment has already shattered
the judicial Norms we we expect and this
makes no sense what was a personal
attack he said she was piling around
with Schumer it's a picture of her with
by the way that's very relevant whenever
this is an individual who's part of his
staff there and this is supposed to be
an impartial judge are you kidding me
this is like the Attorney General is
supposed to be impartial as well these
people have an agenda they have had a
bias obvious bias against Donald Trump
from day one so I think it's very
relevant I think it was appropriate to
call that out that that attorney general
isn't impartial she's very partial she's
very biased she clearly has a political
agenda there's so many horrible crimes
there's so many things happening in New
York City right now and for the city to
spend their resources going after the
former president of the United States
for this is just absolutely ridiculous
in my opinion and a waste of time a
waste of taxpayer money but but also
more importantly just also at the same
time is making Trump more popular than
ever didn't didn't this was Laticia
James right yes yeah didn't she run on
going after Trump absolutely well just
recently there was a a left-wing
activist in New York City who was with
his girlfriend when a deranged man came
up and stabbed him twice killing him no
he he came up to the deranged man let's
be clear the the the news will have you
think that the derang man approached him
he approached the derang man yelling at
him right saying hey hey get trying to
get his attention the derang man turned
on him and was like deranged guy walks
past him knocks over scooters this guy
gets up and yells something says
something to him the guy gets in his
face the dude stands his ground then the
deranged man stabs him killing him and
uh he's still on the loose and he's
still on and I can only say one thing
look these are the activists that voted
in advocated for a DA who is going to go
after the former president instead of
deal with the crime in their own City I
think a lot of the the the thing that
scares me a lot of the part that scares
me about this is that some of them yes
they're emotionally going after Donald
himself but some of them I think the the
deep deep dark thing they're going after
anyone that would do what he was trying
to do by rationalizing our industry like
the people they want I think there's a
global bank I don't know man but all
signs lead the world economic forum and
the New World Order and UL it is a the
world order is changing and that they
want to create this build back better
this this weird digital technocracy you
mean no borders you mean free flow of
people all around do you mean a
centralized yeah banking system you mean
you could just like have it in your head
you just think it's it's it's actually
terrifying you could go down a real dark
hole you could have 10 full hat but the
only thing uh we know about a conspiracy
theory is it's like 6 months until it
actually becomes true generally speaking
Yeah I'm comfortable speaking dis
fervently about it now because of the
last two or three years Russ thing was a
week yeah they're like a coordinated
effort against Russell bran the media is
like what a cooky conspiracy theory and
then we get leaked letters from uh UK
govern the UK government being like we
want him removed we're we're concerned
he can make money on your platform and
then he starts getting banned it's like
oh okay the government was doing as
they're coordinating the hit pieces and
of course releasing key information um
tidbit by tidbit by tidbit to of course
build it up and have the maximum effect
in order to try to hurt him I I think
something very similar is happening with
a lot of these District Attorneys a lot
of them are usually financed by George
and Alex who have financed them who have
bought them off and have created
policies inside of the United States
where you could hurt people you won't go
to jail you won't be in trouble you
defend yourself against individuals
trying to hurt you or steal your
property you go to jail you express
political thoughts and idea you go to
jail but you're you're a criminal you
you could get Lo get loose get free
anytime you want because of these
policies that were implemented without
any kind of vote without any kind of
referendum and all it took was secret
billionaire money that financed these
individuals that were a part of the
larger ideology that these people are
implementing and this ideology is one
that is of course Very uh leftist very
similar to what happened in communism
very similar to of course what happens
in a lot of totalitarian regimes where
people are punished just for their
political Expressions this is this is
the current world that we're living in
which is absolutely terrifying and
should scare the crap out of everyone
because there's no longer a justice
system there's a A system that uses
power to punish people politically Elon
Musk on Twitter or on X rather Elon uh
are we ever going to call it X I'm about
to really TX I like calling it Twitter
still I do it kind everyone like X also
known as Twitter sorry to end you ever
going to call it that cuz a lot of
people don't know what you're talking
about exactly on X it sounds like
ecstasy like I'm tripping I'm on X
everybody's on X right D from pop
culture is calling it Twix that's a good
one well he said that's even more
confusing to yeah he he actually said
the word that um uh George Soros was
figured out how to do politics through
Arbitrage which is basically send a
little bit to a lot of places and just
kind of buy the system by getting all
these local Das and and yeah Court
that's what he does that's crazy that's
nuts what does he do it through multiple
businesses or something I I I don't know
all the ins and outs of the Soros uh
Dynasty and their their multi multip
organizations and and multiple Nos and
multiple ways that they're just
funneling a lot of their money and
financing a lot of these woke leftist
radicals that are in positions of power
and clearly abusing those positions for
their personal benefit but I I I I keep
saying I I think we are winning and by
we I'm referring to the
anti-establishment faction which
includes post liberals Libertarians I
always have to clarify this uh you look
at today and you know one of the Brian
CR I think it was just tweeted this is a
win for Democrats not Republicans it was
eight Republicans who sided with with
Democrats to ask Kevin McCarthy the
Republicans voted to keep them in and
I'm just like yo it it was a win for the
anti-establishment I I it it's obvious
we knew it was going to be Democrats
voting to remove him but and Democrats
are looking at it like I think it's
really funny because democrats should
have actually wanted want him to stand
in he was cutting deals with them but
they can't they're politically trapped
you look at the cultural victories you
look at Matt Gates's massive historic
Victory today anti-establishment is
winning I hope so there there's a quote
from Gates he said something the effect
of uh I'm paraphrasing said based on his
recent conversations with the former
recent based on his recent conversations
with the former president he feels like
he's doing the right thing something
that affect not to say that Trump
actually told him to do it but that Matt
Gates feels confident this is the move
that has to be made I I I believe it is
I believe it's about time someone stood
up to the corrupt mechanisms of Congress
the challenge we face is that for
congress it is always easier to Kick the
Can down the road instead of ripping the
bandaid off and uh Ron Paul had that
famous quote I'm again paraphrasing
where he said you know we got to get out
of Iraq and Afghanistan they keep saying
oh well it was a mistake going in but
now we need an exit strategy so we can't
just leave and he says if if if you
prescrib the wrong medication you don't
just keep them on the same medication
you get them off and it's like yes we've
been sitting by with Congress broken
forever being like well you know it's
going to be bad if we CH it's going to
be bad if we keep doing it we can't we
got to change it some of some medicines
you want to wean off of I I know I know
basically bid surrender in Afghanistan
was like just stopping turkey no I
disagree that was that was that that ter
deliberate thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net